[Musique]
pierre connaissait un bonjour bonjour
nous vous interrogeons aujourd'hui pour
une chaîne youtube qui s'appelle singer
view on vous a déjà reçues sur les
politiques de contrôle radicalisation et
nous sommes attardés un petit peu sur
votre livre qui s'appelle guide du
paradis publicité comparer des au delà
qui nous a fait rire qui nous a
instruits qui nous a fait cogiter et on
a trouvé ça tellement sympa qu'on a
terminé et on a on pourrait comparer
comparer cet ouvrage nous dans notre
langage internet un lonely planet ou un
trip advisor ou un guide du routard du
paradis mélanger avec la pointe d'humour
le cynisme de georges car l'hymne est et
c'est déjà pas mal pierre connaissent a
raconté moi un petit peu la génèse de ce
livre
ce livre a déjà quelques années derrière
lui et il est parti ait de gros stack
qui tenait à mes activités de stratèges
quoi le faire nous aurons juste le col
qui à la coque c'est donc je commence
donc ce livre a déjà quelques années
derrière lui il est il était parti de
mes constats de l'époque où je
travaillais sur les affaires
stratégiques qui était un constat de bon
sens c'est-à-dire que toutes les grandes
religions étaient atteintes par des
formes de radicalisation et en général
tout c'est radicalisation avec hommes
comment dire promesse commune le fait de
garantir l'accès au paradis et puis
ensuite il la guerre en irak et leur sur
la guerre en irak je me suis posé une
question qui est en fait une question de
bon sens c'est-à-dire comme chacun des
deux camps se battait au nom de dieu à
rappelez-vous george bush parlait d'une
croisade et qu'en face on avait
effectivement des gens qui sont
mobilisés essentiellement sur le fait de
la lentille croisade c'est à dire sur le
diane je me suis dit mais finalement les
américains tués par les irakiens
vont-ils au paradis des chrétiens ou
dans l'enfer des musulmans et
inversement et la question est légitime
parce que quand même on peut pas
commencer une guerre sans avoir répondu
à cette question
donc je me suis dit mais depuis le temps
que les hommes se foutent sur la gueule
pour expliquer qu'ils ont le dieu unique
et miséricordieux la seule manière de
rendre compatibles toutes ces théories
c'est dire qu'il ya plusieurs du unique
et c'est effectivement la seule
explication logique de la description
différente des paradis dans les
différentes religions
et donc je me suis dit mais si c'est
l'endroit où on va passer le plus de
temps parce que c'est quand même la vie
éternelle il vaut mieux se renseigner
sur les caractéristiques de chacun des
paradis parce que si on hérite bêtement
de la religion de ses parents on se
retrouve orienté à la fin de sa vie mais
sans avoir fait la commande irles
évaluation du marché
si on considère que la seule loi
effectivement respectées par toutes les
religions c'est la loi du marché donc
que la main invisible d'adam smith est
probablement la main de dieu je me suis
dit il faut que le consommateur se
renseigne et donc j'ai essayé de c'est
écrire ce bouquin c'est à dire
finalement qu'est-ce qui différencie
tous ces paradis quel est le meilleur
moyen d'accéder à celui là plutôt qu'à
celui là et puis surtout si vous voulez
c'est un paysage économique extrêmement
intéressant parce qu'il ya un duo paul
inquiets consomme au dos le
christianisme et l'islam il ya une pme
13 identifié qui le paradis juifs qui
pratiquement sanctuary donc ne cherche
pas à mordre sur les deux autres et puis
un marché de start-up formidable qui est
celui des sectes qui continuellement se
renouvelle avec des promesses nouvelles
avec des explications duel avec des
messies nouveau et donc je me suis dit
effectivement ça vaut la peine de faire
le tour du marché vous êtes penché un
petit peu sur l'église de scientologie
ah ben monsieur horrible sûr parce que
justement le marché se renouvelle par
les sectes c'est ça qui aujourd'hui est
le paysage le plus mouvant le laisser le
secteur en tout genre tout aussi bien la
religion juive que l'islam ou que le
christianisme simplement les différences
c'est que dans le christianisme et dans
la religion suivi dans le pratique
sunnite de l'islam mia dans la pratique
chiite de l'islam il ya des hiérarchies
religieuses tandis qu'en les autres n'a
pas donc c'est toujours très difficile
de les qualifier de sectes parce que en
fait ces religions le sunnisme et le
judaïsme se sont toujours habitués à ce
qui est des gens qui tout à coup
s'annonce comme le messi efface une
nouvelle développe une nouvelle pratique
mais il reste quand on utilise la
sociologie des sectes on se rend compte
qu effectivement c'est un renouvellement
du marché par une promesse
perpétuellement nouvelles dont justement
l'église de scientologie
dans l'ordre du temple solaire dont jim
jones en guyana et c est donc je me suis
dit bon moi mon bouquin s'adresse au
consommateur occidental donc pour pas
qu'ils soient déçus qui je l'aï comment
dire s'égarer dans des sectes comme le
bouddhisme l'hindouisme n'ont pas de
bureau de représentation ici si on est
déçu par ce genre de démarche on n'y a
plus de moyens de se plaindre après donc
je dis restons sur l'offre telle qu'elle
est structuré aujourd'hui c'est à dire
sur les grandes religions présentes sur
le territoire français y compris le le
phénomène sectaire voilà donc j'ai
essayé de faire sa com comme un guide de
voyage c'est à dire ma foi à connaître
le marché connaître les caractéristiques
de chacune des offres comment y aller
commander ma gagner des miles gratuits
et vous poser dix questions
on en choisit une ou n'importe laquelle
n'importe laquelle
comment s'y rendre
ça c'est une question de localisation
géographique parce que d'abord il faut
effectivement faire le choix d'avoir
choisir évidemment le paradis qui
correspond plus à ses moyens et à ses
goûts bon
vous voyez par exemple dans le paradis
bouddhiste théoriquement la fin du
processus devient une espèce de monde on
n'a plus aucune envie bon si c'est ça le
paradis qu'on attend vient il faut mieux
le savoir donc laissons tomber ce genre
de religion par contre il ya des
religions qui ont des offres créé le
faire à convenir très précisément
définies ont pris en particulier l'offre
juin et donc je me suis dit une fois
qu'on a choisi le site la question vient
ensuite c'est à dire d'où partir parce
que évidemment comme toujours il ya se
pose toujours des questions de lieux de
lieux adéquats au départ alors première
remarque que je fais c'est d'abord il
faut éviter les gros départs c'est à
dire quand il ya eu des départs henry 15
heures et en particulier les massacres
et les génocides parce que là il ya des
risques d'encombrement donc il vaut
mieux partir en ayant choisi le moment
deuxième chose il faut choisir le lieu
alors il ya un problème de ce qui est
quand même jérusalem c'est à dire tout
le monde revendique jérusalem comme le
lieu de départ parfait pour aller
directement au paradis
s'il ya quand même quelques points de
départ secondaire parce que comme tous
les grands aéroports comme dubaï
jérusalem est encombré par le nombre de
gens qui viennent là pour mourir mans il
ya des points de départ secondaire selon
la nature de la région qui ont choisi ça
va être la même ça va être lourde ça va
être je sais pas moi
karbala pour les chiites s'est donc
c'est quand même important ça permet de
garder surtout les sectes ont davantage
de diversifier considérablement le point
de départ puisque les sexes n'ayant
jamais réussi à véritablement à déborder
si vous voulez sur la surface de la
planète garantie sur le lieu de départ
de proximité et ça c'est quand même
important parce que si vous êtes à
proximité du point de départ moi vous
savez que le corps le corps n'a pas trop
à se déplacer alors il ya un truc qui
m'a paru très intéressant quand même
c'est que notamment à jérusalem je sais
plus quelle secte juive relu radical
avait demandé qu'on déplace l'aéroport
de tel aviv parce que l'aéroport de tel
aviv passer au dessus d'un cimetière
traditionnel juif mois ce qui laisse
penser qu'effectivement
les corps para directement la verticale
avec le risque de télescopage de l'avion
et c'est intéressant parce que ce départ
à la verticale c'est les méthodes les
plus modernes de lancement de missiles
ces missiles aster c'est-à-dire
lancement vertical parce que ça permet
de partir de toutes les directions donc
ça veut dire qu'effectivement il ya en
tout cas un saut technologique
intéressant bon je crois pas que les
autorités israéliennes aient finalement
décidé de déplacer les aéroports alors
les cas particuliers peut-être sur le
point de départ non obsédé sexuel par
les actes en particulier pour des
profils différents mais différents
passés et en particulier le départ ben
oui parce que beaucoup de questions se
posent quand même
quand je dis pas ça parce que c'est en
ce moment cette affaire dsk on sait
jamais non non non non je pense pas non
non ça c'est la sexualité dsk est pas un
cas particulier
la sexualité est largement traitée dans
l'ancien testament venir salomon il en
avait 6 ans des femmes donc visiblement
je sais pas si dsk tu as ces chiffres là
mais baromètre avait officiellement je
crois quatre femmes est en fait il y en
avait neuf figés autour de lui donc
encore une fois c'est pas le cas dsk est
plutôt normes et si vous laissez pas la
question
les histoires de l'ancien testament sont
à mourir de rire je veux dire le type
qui ce que je réussis plus je crois que
c'est jacob ou à bras je me souviens
plus enfin il fait sa femme ayant
quatre-vingt dix ans je ne viens pas
lieu pu avoir d'enfants lui propose son
esclave c'est là qu'il ya les enfants et
c est finalement sa femme fille décide
finalement à couches le fils de sa femme
devient israël 210 classes d'éveil
ismaël et vous connaissez les problèmes
d'héritage qui ont succédé puisque
finalement chacun se disputent la
paternité mans entre musée juif et
musulman non la question qui m'avait
occuper c'est quand même en fonction de
la nature des prestations qui sont
offertes se pose des questions par
exemple dans le paradis musulmans si
vous êtes un handicapé dans la vie est
ce que vous arrivez entier si vous êtes
mourait à 95 ans est ce que pour honorer
les 72e vous retrouvé vos capacités de
20 ans ou pas est ce que dans le paradis
chrétiens la question se pose pas parce
que finalement quand on regarde les
représentations du paradis ou de la fin
des temps dans le lait type par exemple
les peintures du moyen âge on a
l'impression que les types sorte de la
tombe affublé de chasubles blanches qui
les fait ressembler à des endives et
donc c'est vraiment pas la situation
sexuelle qui va les préoccupent et une
faction de paradigme donc voyez alors la
question je me suis posée c'est
justement comment traiter des cas
particuliers qui sont les bisexuels et
transsexuels les homosexuels les
handicapés etc et finalement on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya beaucoup de réponses
à ces différentes donc il faut chacun
traiter son cas parce que je veux pas
donner tous les trucs quand même qu'ils
sont le résultat de longues recherches
est ce qu'il y avait un particulier qui
vous préoccupe c'est le cas des
homosexuels donc pas pourquoi pas le cas
des homosexuels qui se trouvaient très
amusant qui était quand même le problème
de la destruction de sodome et gomorrhe
dans l'acien testeurs dont vous savez
que le sodome et gomorrhe étaient donc
les deux villes qui étaient des villes
soit consacré à l'homosexualité féminine
soit l'homosexualité masculine bon
finalement dieu décide de détruire ces
deux villes
et il envoie à l'archange gabriel qui
est le messager en général de des bonnes
et des mauvaises nouvelles donc parce
que il a découvert que les deux seuls
jusqu'à le seul juste de la d2 ville
c'était lot et donc il veut sauver
la famille lot et sa famille et
donc quand l'heure quand j'arrive
immédiatement les mecs de sodome en
particulier voit que le type est pas mal
enfin car quand j'ai pas mal ils veulent
faire et lot propose pour les calmer sa
fille jeu quand même pas mal c'est un
grand geste de mansuétude de sympa bon
comme ils sont beaux sexuelle finalement
il laisse tomber et puis donc une fois
qu'il a appris la nouvelle que les
villes va être détruite il donc il s'en
va il quitte la ville
sa femme comme toujours dans les
monothéismes toujours insoumise toujours
incapable de faire bloc de provoquer des
dégâts se retournent en dépit de l'un
des buts de la de l'interdît diva et
finalement se retournant elle est
transformée en statue de sel
le problème c'est comme il est le
dernier homme vivant sur terre avec ses
deux filles la question qui n'est jamais
lui jusqu'à son terme c'est finalement
comment se renouvellent l'espèce
puisqu'il est le seul surveillant avec
deux enfants qui sont les siens et
l'ancien testament explique qu'à ce
moment là ses filles sachant qu'il
fallait renouveler l'espèce le drogue
pour le violet pour avoir des enfants de
lui les mauvais esprits pourraient
penser que c'est une légitimation de la
pédophilie de l'inceste quand même site
un peu scandaleux de le penser comme ça
mais ça laisse quand même planer des
doutes d'envoyer il ya à la fois la
condamnation de l'homosexualité
mais en même temps si la condamnation
d'homosexualité passe par la pédophilie
on peut sous par l'inceste on peut se
poser des questions sur la bonne
interprétation du texte je vais vous
poser une question est ce que vous avez
discuté un petit peu avec les
responsables de ces pme est ce que vous
avez discuté avec les commerciaux non
d'abord parce que moi j'avais une
formation religieuse ensuite parce que
j'ai fait des études d'histoire danger
surtout essayer de voir l'évolution de
ces religions parce que la
caractéristique de ces grands
monothéismes
dont levi strauss et quand même disaient
qu'ils avaient fait faire un énorme pas
l'intolérence 1 quand même puisque
chacune de ces mots nautisme expliquer
les principes premiers mondiaux le bon
elle seule ce qui est quand même pas la
bonne manière de discuter avec les
autres donc la question c'est que une
fois que le texte ça est définie et
chacune de ces religions a le sien le
rôle important c'est celui des exégètes
c'est-à-dire d'expliquer que se tiennent
ce texte contient tout est donc il faut
y trouver la réponse à toutes situations
et donc ses exégètes qu'ils soient
hiérarchie religieuse qu'ils soient
l'imam qui soit grande mosquée al azhar
qui soit le sens ira un peu importe ont
tous fait des efforts intellectuels
extraordinaires pour expliquer qu'en
fait il y avait réponse à dans les
textes donc j'ai pas discuter avec eux
j'aime beaucoup plus me suis beaucoup
plus intéressés à ces différents avatars
qui tout au long de leur histoire
avaient permis de dire une chose et son
contraire là où c'est devenu beaucoup
plus intéressant c'est qu'ils les sectes
étaient d'abord bien eu de révolution la
première c'est évidemment les sectes qui
encore une fois diversifie
considérablement l'offre renouvelle
considérablement la vision du paradis et
le moyen d'y accéder
est ce que dans les sectes quand même
les secte ufologique c'est à dire les
sabres à dire allez bien bien réel donc
là il à eelv outils niveau garanti alors
ce qui est intéressant dans le cadre
c'est que ce type avait un passé de
pilote de course vous voyez en fait il
n'a jamais utilisé ses super pouvoirs
pour gagner une course donc il faut
saluer l'honnêteté intellectuelle de
l'homme parce que finalement on aurait
pu penser que la lui tout seul il était
capable tout les quatorze d'utiliser ses
super pouvoirs mais lui effectivement il
expliquait qu'il avait été donc enlevé
par des petits hommes verts je passe il
était vers une couleur enfin en tout cas
il avait été élevé par un enlevé et que
donc on lui avait appris les super
pouvoirs avec lesquels il a constitué sa
secte et donc il a dénoncé la comment
dire la législation française
interdisant la manipulation génétique
parce qu'il disait on a la possibilité
créer une race des supers sommes le
dernier qui avait essayé les super homme
s'était hitler si je me suis même en
failli lui était pas il avait pas parlé
des petits hommes verts donc si vous
voulez ya toutes ces sectes de type qui
prétendent que le second volant des
petits hommes verts etc alors les sectes
ont très intéressant parce qu'en général
elles sont passées au stade de
l'internet est ce que est ce que vous
pensez que google est une secte google
non pourquoi facebook non non non je
crois qu'il faut pas confondre la les
sectes c'est vraiment un gourou un type
qui a un discours aussi extraordinaire
qui soit et surtout une forme
d'organisation sociale est une emprise
totale sur la communauté avec un
discours vous décrivez google là
pourquoi google et google avec son
leader qui veut améliorer la race
humaine je sais pas j'ai pas suivi et
qu'il faut l'inclure mon corps mon taxi
et d'anciens il à 2004 à l'époque google
avait pas une rôle un rôle aussi
important
mais surtout les sectes on développer la
pratique d'internet on le voit avec les
salafistes aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
là on a la possibilité de faire le tour
de l'offre sans trop se bouger et puis
surtout même dans les grands
monothéismes il ya de plus en plus de
communication par internet interposé
vous par télévision été imposé pendant
l'été les prédicateurs américains sont
de formidables entreprises commerciales
ou le type vous promet le paradis bien
évidemment souvent des fois il vous
annonce même la date de la fin du monde
mais à une date glissantes ont quand
même parce que comme disait l'autre tous
les jours nous rapproche de la fin du
monde ce qui est vrai voilà une
prédiction qui risquent pas d'être
d'être contredite et donc l'été les
prédicateurs qui fonctionnent comme les
télés l'été les imams à l'été les
théologiens d'égypte ou du golfe et donc
qu'ils vous font du discours religieux
avec des promesses avec des explications
des comportements sur la vie quotidienne
etc et puis beaucoup de sites internet
où on vous promet les accompagnements
bon par exemple je cite un site internet
qui vous promet une visite du paradis
qui est une secte américaine il ya un
site internet qui vous vend des
islamistes qui vous vend des senteurs du
paradis
ici en payant carte bleue on obtient une
réduction donc il ya des il ya des tas
de choses à découvrir quoi l'internet
offre permet à une vie une visite très
bien organisée ce que vous posez une
question un peu plus personnelle d'un
croyant en dieu
je pensais jamais rencontré le problème
c'est dispo s'est pas beaucoup intéressé
à moi donc j'en sais rien quand vous
savez la phrase de 68 qui disait dieu
est mort signée nietzsche et le type
avec roots ou nietzsche est mort signée
dieu voilà on est dans cet accord
posture là aujourd'hui un renouveau des
religions ce renouveau des religions il
se fait malheureusement selon des formes
secteur pour beaucoup d'entre elles est
que cette forme secteur sont des formes
incroyablement menaçante pour la
démocratie et on vous parlait de
démocratie
à votre avis ce qui est en train de se
mettre en place pour avoir un dialogue
avec ces pme auprès de ses serres l'état
l'état essaie d'avoir un dialogue avec
ces pme est-ce que vous pensez que ce
dialogue va être opéré en est ce que ce
dialogue à vos sens à votre sens est
inopérant
vous êtes accro celle peut-être alors
devant il ya plusieurs
les pays démocratiques ont eu plusieurs
postures différentes 1 pour les
américains qui est par nature un pays de
refuge de tous tu sais c'est qu'ils
étaient persécutés
en europe le principe de l'indépendance
religieuse est totale c'est à dire que
l'état se refuse à avoir un quelconque
discours religieux ou a condamné
quelques c'est que ce soit et la
scientologie est élevé au rang de
religion et la scientologie reconnue
comme une religion cela dit reconnaître
comme une religion ça veut rien dire du
tout aux etats unis puisque son contrat
il n'y a pas de statut des religions
c'est considéré comme une entreprise
l'été les prédicateurs peuvent faire des
millions de dollars de recettes c'est
pas considéré comme pour nous si vous
voulez de l'abus de faiblesse dans le
fait de la france un peu différent sedan
cas de la france le gouvernement
s'interdit d'avoir un discours religieux
il considère simplement que pour le cas
des sectes par exemple ne sont
condamnables que des pratiques portant
atteinte à des droits individuels ça
veut dire l'abus de faiblesse ça veut
dire le détournement d'enfants des
choses comme ça coule à l'emprise
psychologique et c'est donc la miviludes
qui est la mission interministérielle
devait être de veille contre les dérives
sectaires ne repose que sur des
pratiques condamnables au titre du code
pénal c'est tout mais pas au nom de la
liberté de religion donc c'est très
difficile on peut pas discuter avec des
sacrés encore une fois vous savez faire
descendre un transcendant les faisant
des leçon d'instruction civique on n'a
pas beaucoup eu de succès dans le
domaine c'est vrai
j'aimerais que vous lisez
la phrase d'avant propos de vos livres
concernant la tolérance
l'avant-propos on est dessus page 9
je vous laisse enchaîner
ça c'est une phrase que j'ai
trouvé au cours de mes pérégrinations
qui est une homme une phrase de karl
popper dans son bouquin sur la société
ouverte et ses ennemis dit si long et
d'une tolérance absolue même envers les
intolérants et qu'on ne défendent pas la
société tolérante contre les assauts
contre leur assaut les tolérants seront
anéantis et avec eux la société
tolérante je trouve que c'est une phrase
de bon sens c'est à dire
qu'effectivement
c'est ce que c'est un moment ce que
disent et robespierre pas de liberté
pour les ennemis de la liberté donc il
ya un moment où effectivement la
démocratie les droits de l'homme la
liberté de parole trouve ses propres
limites en particulier quand on aboutit
par exemple à des pratiques sectaires
qui sont des pratiques d'exploitation de
l'homme par l'homme ou comme un abouti à
des appels à la violence ou des appels
au meurtre on est au 21ème siècle est-ce
que vous pensez que notre société
française est de plus ou moins tolérante
je pense qu elle l'est beaucoup plus en
tout état de cause elle est beaucoup
plus que tous les gens qui la condamne
dans le prétendant intolérante dire
quand on entend j'écoutais l'autre fois
dans une émission de radio des
interviews fait en banlieue où des
jeunes musulmans qui admirait quand même
les attentats qui ont eu lieu en janvier
expliqué que leur plaisir était de les
leur désir serait d'aller dans un pays
musulman pour y vivre librement leur
religion
quand j'entendais le terme librement
ça me fout un profond rire l'intérieur
me déchirait quand même parce que vous
contre des filles bas parce que définir
la liberté en disant je vais enfin
pouvoir élire librement de ma religion
qui savent pas ce que c'est qu'un arabie
saoudite c'est une plaisanterie vous
pouvez développer sur l'arabie saoudite
l'arabie saoudite
sédiments sylvie catherine théologique
c'est à dire il ya une relié à une
pratique de l'islam qu'ils emballent
isme qui est une
de la pratique la plus radicale et la
plus littérale si vous êtes la lecture
du courant qui a pris enfin en arabie
saoudite au mot début du 20e siècle
pratiquement depuis le 18è jusqu'au
début du 20e siècle avec la consécration
à la fois de la dynastie saoudienne et
en même temps de la pratique développée
par abdel wahab qui a développé le
wahhabisme quand vous dites consécration
de la famille al saoud oui c'est à dire
que le poulet saoudite saoud a pris le
pouvoir que par cette association de
pouvoir qui est des pouvoirs religieux
et en même temps le pouvoir de la force
mans et donc arabie saoudite est un pays
assez faste fantastique dans lequel
aucune autre religion elle est autorisée
où la charia est appliquée son sens le
plus strict et le plus bête là circule
actuellement sur internet le l'image de
une vidéo de décapitation d'une femme
qui est une pauvre fille venue du
myanmar donc je vois les droits de la
défense dans l'eau un tribunal saoudien
comment l'appeler exercer qu'on accusait
d'avoir maltraité ou d'avoir tué sa
belle-fille je ne sais pas et elle est
exécutée sur un parking public avec des
gens qui tournent autour et c'est bon je
me dis fantastique si on défend l'arabie
saoudite contre l'état islamique je dois
dire qu'on va avoir un match formidable
donc on a un il faut s'imaginer ce que
peut-être une ville d'arabie saoudite
une vie dans laquelle n'ya pas de cinéma
y'a pas de théâtre il n'y a pas de lieu
culturel si cela la mosquée et cac des
centres commerciaux
on peut se dire qu'effectivement
la seule envie qu'on peut avoir c'est de
s'en aller bon le problème avec l'arabie
saoudite c'est quand ben laden voulait
exporter le modèle puisque en fait
c'était un peu son idée même s'ils
étaient en désaccord et quatrième set
mais en tout cas le modèle qui veulent
exporter c'est celui là
d'habitude on jeudi dans un asile
psychiatrique le fou ils essaient de
sauver pour trouver le monde normal
extérieur lui voulait exporter le modèle
c'est quand même paradoxalement sur le
plan psychanalytique ça mériterait une
analyse et donc vous avez une société
dans laquelle les gens vivent les
apparences c'est à dire qu'ils font
comme s'ils étaient de très bon
pratiquant pétition à l'extérieur vous
avez exactement le déchaînement de
toutes les pratiques les plus
effroyables que l'argent permet
voire une fusion etc vous aurez pu
évidemment comme de toute façon en
arabie saoudite
on trouve de l'alcool en connaissant les
bons réseaux de distribution on trouve
de la drogue etc vous avez des problèmes
d'alcoolisme et met les familles qui ont
de l'argent envoient leurs enfants pour
des alcoolisations pour curieux le
traitement anti drogue et ira dans des
cliniques privées très huppé en suisse
c'est quand même là qu'on a sur
l'anonymat le plus complet pour ce genre
de choses donc on est dans une société
qui est totalement hypocrite
mais qui a beaucoup d'argent donc quand
on est un peu hypocrite fait beaucoup
d'argent faut faire attention si on veut
de l'argent il vaut mieux respecter son
hypocrisie si on veut être honnête qu'on
dénonce une hypocrisie et pour vous pour
vous là les plus hypocrites ce sont les
saoudiens ou ceux qui traitent est le
saoudien je sais pas parce que je suis
quand même c'est une question difficile
vous savez quand ben laden dans son
programme de candé l'époque où il
voulait appliquer sur le système utile
qu'on a découvert avec les attentats du
11 septembre
il avait désigné comme ennemi les
hypocrites à leur jour à sion et
hypocrite sais pas vous mais moi j po
créé parce que sinon il y aurait plus
personne à surface des planètes dans les
hypocrites c'est les mauvais croyais en
mes mots les croyants c'est à dire ceux
qui croient pas comme lui en
l'occurrence était sain donc si c'est la
catégorie hypocrite au sens ben laden du
terme c'est une chorale intra musulmane
c'est ce qui se passe actuellement il se
massacrent entre sunnites chiites entre
heuliez entre al-qaïda et d'alès et
c'est
malheureusement peut rien faire pour eux
il est vivant découvrir au bout d'un
siècle que la tolérance surtout une
vertu que mal le coran n'enseigne pas et
que les autres grandes religions
monothéistes n'enseigne pas mais enfin
je vais faire on peut pas il fait grand
chose pour le reste c'est à dire est-ce
qu'on peut négocier avec le diable
ça fait des siècles on le fait
ce fait des siècles donc je ne sais pas
si encore une fois quand on négocie avec
le diable il faut une longue cuillère ça
on est d'accord mais encore une fois on
y est habitué
dernière question avant dernière
question
quand quand vous avez été amené à
discuter de ce livre avec daudou de
personnes ayant un trait aux forces de
l'ordre avec l'armée ou peut-être
pas non non on tient là non ça n'a pas
posé de questions c'est pas de lacs sont
venus les ennuis ce qui est rigolo c'est
qu'une fois que j'ai été attaqué en
diffamation et vous devinerez jamais
parti l'église catholique non j'ai été
attaqué en diffamation par l'association
de défense des intérêts moraux de
l'ordre du temple solaire alors madame
solaire du mandarom pardon madame
l'allemande à rome vous vous souvenez
c'était gilbert bourdin le type qui
prétendait tous les soirs se bat contre
les lémuriens jeu peut brûler les murs y
sommes en phase 6 qui disait pour sauver
la planète et donc vous savez il avait
conçu ces immenses statues en provence
la danse qui sont restés là bas puis
ensuite il ya eu une action en justice
qui est entamée contre lui notamment
pour des pratiques de
pédophiles etc mais comme il est mort
trop tôt on n'a jamais su le fin mot de
l'histoire toujours est il qu'à une
association de défense des intérêts
moraux du monde arabe qui m'a un jour
attaqué en diffamation uniquement sur ce
point c'est à dire sur le fait que j'ai
évoqué les possibles pratiques
pédophiles de gilbert goergen son vrai
nom est donc en fait comme il y avait
prescription disque en matière de
diffamation la prostitution est très
très content très brève bon ils se sont
en matière de diffamation il ya deux
techniques soit vous l'attaquez au civil
soit gaulle attaque au pénal si vous
attaquez pas aux civils vous vous
défendez sans avocat si vous attaquez au
pays il faut prendre un avocat donc ils
ont essayé de me faire payer un avocat
c'est tout puis comme illusions perdues
à cause de forclusion ça s'est arrêté là
mais c'est pour dire que contrairement à
ce qu'on peut penser les réactions ne
sont pas venus de ce qu on ne penserait
les plus attaquées peut-être parce que
justement ils sont eux mêmes divisés sur
le sur leur propre définition du paradis
et des moyens d'y accéder on va on va
finir cette interview pour une dernière
question si vous aviez à l'essai un
conseil aux jeunes générations
d'abord acheté mon livre tiens vous
permettra de vous prémunir contre les
excès de toute nature de toutes les
certitudes qui vous sont infusés par les
uns ou par les autres ça c'est un point
absolument important
ensuite je dirais que la place de pro d2
claudel je crois que si je dit à la fin
qui dit que à chaque fois que l'homme
vous voulez créer le paradis sur terre
il a surtout mené directement un enfer
sur terre et malheureusement tous les
exemples le site c'est à dire tous ces
intégristes qui ont voulu ici sur la
planète créer quelque part une espèce de
paradis selon les principes les plus
obscurantistes on ait pu inventer que ce
soit les talibans à l'époque de kaboul
ce soit calvin à genève
où d'autres exemples de cette nature à
chaque fois ça a été un monde effroyable
de répression d'interdît d'interdiction
de la musique d'interdiction du jeu
d'interdiction de tas de choses de
répression sur les femmes donc à chaque
fois ils se sont réunis dans la feue la
forme la plus effrayante de ce qu'on
peut imaginer qu'être l'enfer sur terre
juste une remarque pour terminer parce
que il ya quelque chose qui m'avait
frappé ou ans des attentats du 11
septembre on avait trouvé dans la
chambre d'hôtel de mohammed atta le
leader du groupe une description de ce
qu'il pensait de ce qu'ils croyaient
l'attendre après sa mort et donc il
disait qu effectivement il alors il
aurait donc dans le paradis qui lui
était promis il avait testé un petit peu
avant alors là non ça va c'est plus
compliqué que ça c'est à dire qu'il
savait que comme lui ai promis il
attendait donc du vin qui ne saoule pas
et puis 72e
le problème c'est que convaincus par les
saoudiens de cette pratique terrible
l'islam il était à mon avis face à un
problème
de schizophrénie profonde parce que si
vous imaginez que le vin et les femmes
pour un saoudien s'est quand même les
états unis qui est quand même décrit
comme l'enfer sur terre et que par
contre l'enfer est décrit comme le
soleil le caillou et le désert c'est à
dire l'arabie saoudite cette espèce de
glissements d'image qui fait que quand
on a su refaire ce qui doit s y est
décrit comme l'enfer et on a sur terre
s'il est décrit comme pour le paradis
l'arabie saoudite pour aller là bas et
découvrir que le paradis c'est ce qui
est les etats-unis et puis l'enfer c'est
ce qui est des crimes l'arabie saoudite
c'est un moment où les images si vous
laissez comme le playback amont où
l'image et le son se se recoupent pas je
sais pas comment il a résolu le problème
suivant rajouter quelque chose
non il ya une histoire que j'ai trouvé
très bonne aussi c'est l'histoire d'une
famille palestinienne
il y avait un attentat organisé avec
deux femmes qui se succèdent et qui
avaient chacune une ceinture de de
l'explosif et donc l'idée c'était de
faire comme souvent dans les attentats
staller première se faisait exploser
quand les services de secours arrivent
et ils vont te remettre la seconde
devait faire exploser sa sa ceinture bon
or le souffle de l'explosion de la
première a assommé la seconde qui s'est
retrouvé s'est réveillé dans une chambre
toute blanche avec des gens qui
s'occupait d'elle c'est qu'il a soignée
mois elle s'est dit chauffard a dit
péter équipe est encore meilleure parce
qu'à ce moment là elle avait plus son
truc qu'ils avaient démonté il avait en
réalité dans une chambre toute blanche
avec des gens qui étaient autour d'alain
médecins qui la soignent et c'est donc
assez du show paradis des gens ayant dit
non vous n'êtes pas au paradis vous
n'êtes pas morte mais si le paradis le
paradis c'est comme ça je vois bien il
ya des gens qui s'occupent de moi est le
type le médecin qui était là il céda
quand elle voulait pas le convaincre
finalement il a utilisé l'argument
suprême il dit c'est pas le paradis
puisque je suis juif je suis médecin
juif et 2 seul coup pour elle s'est
écroulée si vous
la description de son paradis donc voilà
il faut rester modeste face aux
promesses pierre conesa merci merci à
vous
[Applaudissements]
tous les
jours
[Musique]
il vaut mieux l inhumanité
[Applaudissements]